. Let's go next to.
Why don't we go to Thibeault from Brussels,
Belgium, Thibeault, you're on the air.
Hi, David.
Can you hear me?
I can hear you perfectly.
So first, I wanted to ask, how are people
coping in America with the stimulus checks?
Because I am raised by a single mother and
she has a beauty salon, and in Belgium, all
the contact jobs or close contact jobs had
to close for several months.
And my bride is gone every month.
She got an amount of money proportionate to
her income.
And I just can't imagine how Americans can
live without paychecks for so many months.
It's it's there's a there's a range.
I mean, you know, fortunately lots of people
had jobs that translated to work from home,
but many people did not.
Of course, a lot of people are on unemployment
and struggling on unemployment.
In fact, we did a story earlier this week
on the bonus show.
That's the award winning bonus show.
Thibeault, by the way, we did a story on the
bonus show about how one third of those receiving
unemployment in February were struggling to
pay for food and housing so that even people
on unemployment are struggling.
Right now, a lot of younger people have moved
back in with parents.
I mean, there's not one.
It's a very good question.
There's not one answer.
But different people are coping in different
ways and to different degrees.
But it's pathetic what what hasn't been done
here compared to what Europe has done.
Yeah, and like I said, also in America, that
also certain jobs had to just close for several
months, or is it just the state by state legislated?
Well, the answer is yes, but it was based
on a state by state basis.
So there were long periods where in certain
states things like, you know, massage therapy
was just closed, hair salons closed, things
like this, it is decided upon at the state
level.
So there's kind of like a different answers
in different states.
But, yeah, that was that was the case.
OK, I understand.
And I just wanted to ask you also about Bernie
Sanders.
Sure.
Like he is, I believe, the chairman of the
Senate Budget Committee.
Right.
Like, what is what are his powers or what
can he basically get done for you guys?
It's not clear.
I mean, listen, the powers are enumerated.
You could just Google exactly what the powers
are.
And it has to do with agenda setting in that
in that committee.
What he can do unilaterally is very much unclear.
And he's still going to need to build consensus
with the broader Democratic Party, I think.
But it's still a good thing to have him in
that role.
But if people are expecting Bernie to unilaterally
get a ton done because he's in that position,
I think that that expectation probably will
leave you disappointed.
And did the establishment give him that position
or did he get suited to that chair position?
He was voted to.
He was selected by the Senate for that.
I mean, isn't that, like, pretty great for
progressive?
Absolutely.
I mean, the question will be things are abnormal
right now because of the pandemic.
Once things normalize, then we will get to
see, OK, from the progressive agenda, what
will be done and what can Bernie help push
along in his role as Senate budget chairman?
We just don't know yet.
Mm hmm.
Because like in the House, like the progressive
candidates like ABC, yeah, they just didn't
get like any high positions.
Right.
That is essentially correct.
And we will see if that changes in 20, 22.
Yeah, OK, thanks, things and Christians.
Thank you.
So how are things OK in Brussels otherwise
it's one of my favorite cities.
Yeah, we just had, like, some really bad news,
we had an incident and not yesterday, but
the day before with gay bashing.
Oh, so some young people went on a gay meeting
up and they made contact with an old man.
They just.
Waited on him like in a park or something,
and that man was killed.
Oh, my sexuality.
So we're currently facing that and like the
whole country is now.
Yeah, a little bit shocked.
That's that's horrifying to end on a high
note, can you still get the really great fries
in Brussels with the different sources, or
is that shut down because of the pandemic?
We have the best fries in the world right
now.
I don't disagree.
Are the French fries were originally from
Belgium, so you can say they are really French
fries, but and we made the best fries and
yet we still have them.
But a lot of Chinese people come come to Belgium
to, like, open.
How do you say it's like a French fry business?
OK, I'm afraid I have.
Yeah, we have so many, but they make really
good French fries.
But yeah, it's really funny.
What's your favorite sauce, the curry ketchup
or what?
Oh, no, we have this one, so it's called the
GOP sauce, OK?
It's like this yellow sauce.
I don't know where it's coming from, but come
to bed.
It could be anything.
Yeah, no, no.
I've been to Belgium.
I tried a bunch of the sausages.
I did not I did not try that one.
But yellow.
I will go for any day, you know.
Yeah.
All right.
Thibeault from Brussels, I appreciate it.
Thank you.
Bye.
All right.
Wow.
Wow, what a call.
All right, let's take a quick break.
If you're holding to talk to me, please don't
hang up, because I'm going right back to the
phones in just
a moment.
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.